et pour jean pierre colombiès
porte-parole de l'union des policiers
nationaux indépendants et michel fize
sociologue le gouvernement peine à
clarifier la situation
ce gouvernement s'est inscrit dans une
dynamique d'absence de dialogue de
radicalisation des positions qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui il est forte à forte à
craindre que toute proposition tout
projet toute réflexion de ce
gouvernement ce ne soit tout simplement
pas entendable et j'avais dit déjà à
l'époque au début de la crise des îles
et jaune que il était à craindre
ce que nous constatons aujourd'hui ce
que je déplore c'est que tout débat
politique aujourd'hui ne revienne sur le
seul et même débat seul et même thème
c'est celui de l'opposition entre la
police et ça et sa citoyenneté sa
population et ça c'est particulièrement
catastrophique
c'est ça mon sens ce qui met
véritablement en danger les fondements
mêmes de notre de notre pacte social qui
est particulièrement malmenées ces
derniers mois le gouvernement est au
milieu de toutes ces insécurité et il
est vrai que le discours tenu au jaune
hier et qui est un discours très
mosaïque
je partage tout à fait ce qui vient
d'être dit c'est un discours qui veut
ménager la chèvre et le chou donc
reconnaissant d'un côté qu'il y à des
violences deux policiers mais que les
policiers sont eux mêmes victimes de
violences comme s'il y avait une sorte
de de compensation dans dans le discours
et c'est vrai qu'on voit pas très bien
vers kehl vers quelle stratégie l'on va
étant entendu que cette affaire de black
blocks est une affaire très ancienne
elle remonte pour sa partie très
contemporaine à deux ans maintenant avec
l'ouverture du conflit ddj les jaunes y
envoie pas très très bien à la stratégie